all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel
um guys
I am officially back into my coffee
habit and I need to quit again I need to
quit again
I'm sorry if the people that are
disappointed in me I understand
um but today I'm
I want to talk about
um
how it doesn't matter how much you do
for someone you should never expect them
to be thankful
but reward the people that are thankful
because that is a rare a rare case
um so I want to talk about as you guys
know I've been in a media like hit store
and it's just been mad like crazy you
know people are calling me fat which
okay you know I could lose 10 pounds but
whale territory
that's a bit extreme you know I've been
accused of being a liar right and it's
funny because they'll misconstrue the
stats because
um I was talking about how women are
fatter than men right and so what you
know the reaction channels will do is
they'll say
um basically there was a clip where I
was with another YouTuber and he told me
that women were not fatter than men that
men were fatter than women
and I was confused because I swore women
were fatter than men
and he leaves right
um and he corrects me I look it up on
the on the show right and he corrects me
and I'm like okay yeah I know it's wrong
okay
but I look into it after the show and
when they take into account like waist
circumference the women are actually
fatter than the men and when they take
into account
um
muscle mass
because if a dude is 260 pounds or maybe
not I don't know 240 I guess 220
um six foot two twenty he could be
jacked but a woman she's fat like there
I know I don't know I mean there's
exceptions right but the rule and so I
was looking into it and the level of
women that are like morbidly obese is
higher than the level of men that are
morbidly obese and I talk about whales
but since these reaction channels
already like hate me
you know they're just like oh you're a
liar Liar Liar Liar Liar Liar and they
never reach out to me and ask me for my
take even though I've never spoken about
these people right
um
not you know before sometimes I'll
respond you know but they always start
it and it's crazy because what they'll
do is like imagine you're a bear they'll
make poke poke poke bear bear right
you're the bear they just keep poking
the bear then you respond
and they act like you're obsessed with
them when I'm like
um excuse me
you guys have made like 10 videos on me
I respond once and anyways crazy right
so during this media hit storm it's
basically given
anybody that's had a problem with me
ever to make a video about me
and all the things they say is they
don't they basically don't like my
opinions now
and they don't feel like I believed that
before and I've been like super honest
about this how I used to be very blue
pill and I moved into red pill and
that's you know my whole phrase on my
channel is once you see it you can unsee
it but the and I've always been a
conservative right but red pill is a
little different than conservative and
I've spoken about how my opinions have
changed over time but it's so funny
because all the reaction channels will
be like oh you're a liar you're this but
they never ask me for my point of view
ever
um and you know these reaction channels
will admit they didn't like me before
and now
they still don't like me so they they
paint a narrative they don't look for
the truth it's just Pearl's a bad person
right
and why I want to talk about gratitude
is this gave the opportunity for anybody
that doesn't like me
to make a video about me
and I really got to see people's True
Colors so
um like for example I had one friend
that I like we fell off like I don't
know a year and a half ago-ish and she
basically comes forward
um and you guys know how when girls kind
of lie like they insert a little bit of
Truth into a lie I don't know if you've
ever experienced this like they'll say
something that's half true and kind of
allude to things and like whatever and
this is someone like I grew up with like
I thought we were like best friends like
literally best friends and when I
started doing this stuff um I started
talking about fat chicks and she kind of
got a bit
bigger right uh no fat like no offense
star and I didn't really know that and
so she would just start taking like
things personally and she was like
trying every time like I would do a show
she didn't like she'd always just be in
my ear and I just was like you can
either watch it or not
um and she decided to not be friends
with me and I
didn't I said okay fine I didn't argue
with her I didn't and like this it was
weird she like got even matter when I
said okay you said you didn't want to be
my friend
now mind you this girl when I I was in
high school
there is so much I I helped her with
like I would always drive to go see her
um I freaking
what do you call it
um we let her live with my family or
like in our family house for free in the
Summers uh there was a time I even like
did a test for her in college I lend her
money
um and it's crazy because when women
feel slighted
they don't care
um and it doesn't matter all of the
things that you have done for them you
know and I don't say this to throw it in
their face but objectively like it's
kind of nice to
you know let someone stay with you for a
summer for free you know it's just stuff
like that
um but it really showed me like female
nature in a way
because
um again it showed me that it doesn't
matter how nice you are to someone if
they feel a certain way they're gonna do
it
um the other thing that happened
was I actually had
someone really close to me steal from me
now
um and this was someone like I thought
was my friend it was so it was so crazy
and I literally
um and it's funny because she doesn't
even know I know this is a funny thing
um but I had someone like super close to
me steal for me and like
and it's funny because this person like
thought was my friend
um
I
helped her you know I don't really want
to go into some of the stuff but it's so
crazy like I just this whole like
journey to fame has shown me like the
dark part of human nature because I
always like assume the best in people
um and then you guys already know the
the co-host guy right
um I don't even want to say names but it
was someone that like I worked with I
filmed content with and I genuinely
thought he was my friend and then
um you know one day this this guy wakes
up
um and during this whole thing he sort
of chased me down for a contract right
he says he didn't but yeah semantics
right
um and then he didn't like the contract
I offered him so he called me a
colonizer and then started talking about
all of the other contracts that were
offered you know
um when he'd never seen them and it and
then oh gosh and I'm not even trying to
get too into it my point is that
what it's shown me is
one
you have to be careful who you deal with
because if you deal with people that
have nothing to lose
and that's this is the sad part about
like getting to a certain point when
you've built something great when you
deal with people that have nothing to
lose
it is a major risk and I realize this is
what men go through and this is why I've
heard wealthy men say they actually do
go for women with money
um or like with careers it's not because
they're attracted to it but it's because
when you deal with people that have
nothing to lose it becomes a Flight Risk
and especially when people make money
off of
um off of you when people make money off
of your name
um they are now like imagine every
ex-friend ex-boyfriend ex-girlfriend is
being offered money
to
um say things about you and I mean for
me it's crazy the biggest thing they got
is her opinions have changed over time
I thought I thought that's what people
do I actually used to believe in
I used to be in college I was slightly
liberal but I was never that liberal you
know what I mean my dad always used to
tell me if you don't
um if you're in college and you don't
have a
if you're not liberal you don't have a
heart but
if you're not conservative by 40 you
don't have a brain or some phrase like
that but what it's shown me is that
you have to be really careful and I say
this to like young people that if you
want to get on the internet someday if
you want to like build a brand even I
don't care how young you are you have to
be so careful with who you pick
because when people are offering money
to say bad things about you and that's
what's happening to Trump right now
um that's what happened to Brett
Kavanaugh some crazy lady he spoke he
probably spoke to at a party in college
or maybe hooked up with her I don't know
um
then they paint him as the bad guy
and it's imagine and that's the crazy
thing with the tapes now imagine every
ex-girlfriend do you know many girls
those men have screwed
oh my gosh like I'm just assuming right
based on their content but they're in
Romania they're super wealthy they're
good looking
and it's actually amazing that this few
people have come out about them like
it's what I've been what five I think so
I don't know it's something that I
didn't expect and really honestly it's
changed my view on the world because
there were people that I never in a
million years thought would do that and
I guess you know
um but it's also made me really
appreciative for the people you know
that were loyal to our
our brand right because you know I had a
producer like sit me and blessing down
the other day and just talk tell us you
know
how thankful he is to work here and we
had other people that were you know
defending us so it's just
it makes you really appreciative for the
people that stuck up for you it does
disappoint you and like kind of human
nature but at the end of the day
um it really taught me a lesson to be
careful who you let in your circle and
to really deal with people that have
something to lose because and especially
guys because guys have even more to lose
than women do if I'm being honest
um and especially girlfriends because
these women or feminine men they run to
the internet let me tell you
[Music]
so I don't know 10 minute thought I just
had
um but let me know what you guys think
uh like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel I'll talk to
you next time